back-to-back lunatic ex again let's see
what he does against you form some Slav
kind of thing maybe we get them accepted
right again but which is a total mess
let's see what he what he comes up with
many many possibilities for black hair
okay yeah this is a decent line and
Bishop takes luck has some very
reasonable chances here I still like
white but it's not it's not like
blankets in huge trouble or anything Wow
okay so we will just allow Steve for
let's say quite surprising now this
Bishop will be taken and he has to take
with a pawn just not exactly ideal ideal
oh okay so what about it is
hmm somewhat surprising him y'all
understand the point he does not want to
have this um doesn't want to have an
isolated pawn down but still I am
winning also quite some time here what
happens are to this 2006-7 I guess on
Queen 86 I don't know this is
interesting changing course here a
little bit but because I can win time on
the night as well we should have form
but maybe you can just play night after
the seven yeah this really okay I don't
understand it
he doesn't have a check on c5 or
anything so I don't see a trick here and
if he moves the night ii five just
winced material of a wide be sure t to
EF six so we has to play you guys to
play this one and now I can can grab on
d5 I just wonder I just wonder how to do
this exactly on 95 55 55 look 28 this is
this is the thing I'm sitting in a pin
down okay I can take also I can also
take with the bishop and go for some
night differ it's not bad let's let's do
that it's an interesting idea and then
night to deform okay why why did he do
that so he thinks he just has
compensation that's possible yeah that's
actually possible if I can take if I
take and direct the idea that's
compensation but I wanted to do this and
then be three and just play on the
strategic own edges that I have ok so
that's an interesting one that is six
looks very tempting but I know that's
good actually
I can just take but nine is six isn't
all that clear knight c6 there's a check
neither five this also a check and I
came okay let's do that keep it simple
method maybe that's wrong all right I
defended that quite well I mean the
opening play was pretty bad but this is
this is now quite quite interesting fan
let's see okay Bishop 96 I have Bishop
e3 this is kind of important it equals
now Wow okay
those pins are kind of annoying way to
get out of the spins I mean I could just
run with the King to d3 this is possible
let's do that
you
he just wants to push the pawns all the
way okay so
you
okay the way for and I cannot take
because of 94 it's a tricky move check
time warning check check
you
that's it's not easy in let's go this
check check check check hey why smirk
actually attacked what that's very weird
very strange sequence ok now ok i
blundered that one white resides how did
that happen
okay Shang kids I did I'd actually
didn't see that my report saying okay
that debt he defended very well he had a
totally rotten position very nicely
defended yeah so as position just
totally sucks for black it just totally
sucks and but I didn't refute it well
here here the big question is like ecigs
am ok the computer wants to play this
move which is in which is nice probably
because taking night is six should win
so inserting this forces him to go here
and then e6 okay it's still kind of kind
of tricky
it's not easy to play I mean it doesn't
help that stock first things he win
certainly to stop which would win this
but it's a it's tricky I didn't see the
idea though that I can insert be three I
mean just as this is also nice you know
but I think I made a couple of wrong
decisions 11 is that I should go here
actually and not going to the pin this
is this was a this was a bad idea I'm in
a pin down be tuned and this is now much
easier to play because I can I mean he
has a bad porn structure right and in
the game he manages to to trade all
those pawns yeah with a four and so on
and by now it's it's okay for him almost
yeah it'sit's chalo here here my child
she cannot be 2m turn Jensen somewhere
LTM I'm I went astray the engine still
likes white which I am I'm quite
surprised yeah well maybe ever he also
has some weird things going on fam King
you too is what the engine wants to do
ideas to go rook c5 try to pick this up
yeah well that's difficult chat and I
didn't play it well i mean i was
chatting somewhat hectic and gave up
that poem the Rope ending i think should
be a little bit check I screwed it up
this is this check yeah okay they
mediate f5 is better but I still don't
think this is all that much of a problem
maybe I'm wrong
ok here it could be ok maybe g5 lattice
it's gotten more tricky than it should
be the easiest is probably to do this
now and then come up with the pawns I
just need to trade a little bit more I
will always draw against the single deep
one but Jack yeah it's it's difficult
check I totally totally overlooked ya
hear that Marik hangs but it's losing
already I cannot chef 6am doesn't do
anything but it's probably losing
already we do this the deep one is going
to be too strong hmm that was a tough
game another tough game now with quite
some chances but he defended this is bad
position very well ok thanks for
watching